abone ol
[Alkış]
ve
70'lerde yaşayan olmuş
Seksenler'deki piş piş
o o o
Fiat 500L
mı
Hiçbir şey yok
18 gibi o
like
atıp
sosyal bil
bu
işte o
[Müzik]
abone ol
sen biliyorsun geldi
bu
Mersin'de
Çünkü
[Müzik]
akla o
O nasıl oldu dedi bu Yonca kolay
nasıl yani kitap okuyan mı
ve içlerini daire
[Müzik]
yapıyoruz o
İyi o zaman
görüşürüz o
bu dünyanın büyük Merkezi i
bu sonra iki gün Afyon Çünkü o
[Müzik]
Ne demek istiyorsun
araç
amacı
yönetmen ve kalifiye
geçirmek değil mi o
Ne değişti
şimdi bugün konuşuyoruz
böyle yapıyoruz
[Müzik]
Çünkü o
bu ver sınavında vereceğim gibi ama
vardı dediğimiz
hayatın istediğiniz bilgilere girebilmek
hayallerimizi araçlarımızı gerçek mi
ve hatta her şey soruyorum kızım
bisikleti
tercih
böyle bir o
Yok yok yok
montaj Yok yok
Sesli yok bizim
Ama
gerçekten o
ne yapmış bir şey oluyor
Gerçekten ne istediğini bilmek ve doğru
geliyorum şimdi
Sen
dışarı çık demek
şimdi biz
bu hayatta değiştiriyoruz benim hayalim
oluyoruz
kendimizi dışarıda o
Ben de şu an kendine uyguluyorum sırada
bir işareti ne çocuğu olarak devletsiz
sadece
yetersiz ne o
[Alkış]
15 konuşmalarımız Hakan Bey'in Tiyatrosu
oyuncusu yazar
1967'de Samsun Terme'de duvar ilk
tiyatro sahnelerine ol